why are you upset with me your employees
are the ones putting a damper on the
party they are acting terribly
you're the one who's been acting
terribly tonight you've been curd and
snobby with my guests
you've been needling poor peralta so
much you practically made him a new suit
needled him a new suit even when we're
fighting you're hilarious stop it stop
it
hello again professor kevin kosner
what do you want i'd like to tell you
about a case i solved
thank you but just as with my home my
office has a strict no cop talk policy
i figured but the case that i've solved
is the case of the no cop talk policy
there were three things that bothered me
about last night you didn't want the
nine-nine at your party even though
you've never met us
your friends immediately asked hitchcock
and scully if they were harassed
and there was something interesting
about that photo in your library you and
the captain were shunted off to the side
i don't think you dislike cop talk i
think you dislike cops
i'm married to one i know and i can't
imagine it's been fun watching the man
you love
marginalized underappreciated and
disrespected by the nypd
because he's gay raymond has been put
through hell by his colleagues many of
whom quite frankly
look exactly like you devastatingly
handsome
i'm sorry i'm uncomfortable with
emotions so yes i decided a long time
ago that just because i love raymond
doesn't mean i have to love the people
he works with
good solve detective nice cop lingo
look i'm really sorry that we ruined
your party
i'd like to make it up to you captain
thank you for joining us what's going on
a proper birthday dinner
amy chose the restaurant captain
oh perfect i've always wanted to come
here boyle pick the menu
vivian helped terry chose the champagne
i'm sorry about your party sir i tried
to keep them in line but i failed well
that's not your job i'm only sorry you
didn't get a chance to enjoy yourself
gina has brought back all the silverware
that she stole from your house
what also this clock good heavens
this isn't ours and my contribution will
be to refrain from discussing the new
yorker
for the rest of my living days thank you
jake you're welcome kevin
call me kev huh right oh he told you to
say that didn't he well you are always
playing pranks on me raymond just once
let me be the funny one
and finally it is my great pleasure to
introduce the nine-nine zone detective
scully to serenade you
[Applause]
oh
tomorrow's my anniversary with kevin
i'd like to cook him an impressive
breakfast could you help
orient me with that process i'd be
honored preparing food for one's lover
is the most
intimate gift of all aside from washing
their hair
okay well you hear that sizzle that
means the heat is a little too high on
those eggs
well the the higher the heat the faster
the eggs cook the sooner kevin eats am i
incorrect no you make an excellent point
but we don't want to feed kevin burned
garbage
good morning boyle oh good morning
captain holt after our disagreement
yesterday i went online to read your
culinary blogs
and scoff to my dismay i actually
learned something
about how food tells a story so i made
kevin this
it's warm it's a croak monsieur kevin
and i shared one on a rainy afternoon in
paris
on our first anniversary it's one of our
most treasured memories
i'm sure it's not up to your standards
but kevin seemed to enjoy it
so thank you for your guidance
it's amazing i don't care for it
but i tried and what a story for kevin
my question is could something have
happened at home before he left for work
well i remember that morning he left
this house at seven and was in a great
mood in fact he was still chuckling
about the previous night's charlie rose
fine so your marriage might not be the
problem well this is where raymond eats
breakfast every morning
yes i know he's always raving about how
they don't have specials
diane hello this is my friend gina and
this is detective peralta
they work with my raymond are you sure
we're talking about last wednesday
positive haven't seen him since
you haven't um
i'm sorry i need to leave excuse me
kevin jeff what's going on
raymond has been lying to me three
mornings this week he told me he was
fencing with dan
why would he do that why would he lie to
me i don't know maybe it's connected to
his bad mood my husband does not lie to
me
this investigation of yours was a bad
idea i'm going home i have to sort this
out with raymond
why would you keep this from me and why
would you lie about going to fencing
because he couldn't go because he's
injured
i wasn't injured i was lightly stabbed
i'm sorry you were stabbed
lightly stabbed i didn't want to
frighten you
you are my husband i want you to tell me
everything
especially things that might frighten me
how can you not know that you want to
know why i was so angry all week
when those men came at me i acted like i
was a 20 year old
i took a stupid risk and i got myself
stabbed
i was in pain and frustrated
about lying to the man i love kevin yes
obviously kevin obviously what did the
officiants say when you got married not
much
when gay marriage was legalized we
weren't sure if or when it was going to
be struck down so speed
was of the essence and do you kevin yes
and do you yes yes we do we're married
i remarked afterwards that i wish the
officiant had been more
efficient it was very funny kevin still
talks about it
marriage is a contract
but it's so much more than that marriage
is love
it's commitment it's joy
it's understanding it's patience it's
anger it's reconciliation
it's everything it's like oatmeal
it sustains you
darlene do you take lynn to be your
lawfully wedded husband
i do lin do you take darlene to be your
lawfully wedded wife
i do i now pronounce you husband and
wife you may kiss the bride
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i got to hand it to you captain that was
some ceremony but it wasn't difficult i
simply
said what i wish had been said when
kevin and i got married
oh well then i never would have heard
your hilarious efficient official quip
you're right i regret nothing but all
this does make me
think i might enjoy a more festive
expression of our commitment to one
another
are you suggesting we hold an
honest-to-goodness wedding oh
nothing too elaborate we're not the
kardashian west's after all
they are a musician and a celebrity
personality who recently wedded yes yes
i know
they were answers on jeopardy i think
you mean questions
[Laughter]
you guys are fun hello raymond
ready to go to dinner yes but i have
some unfortunate news about our pie
it was thrown away no are you serious
mm-hmm
and i know who did it who you all
bragged about your
thanksgiving plans why
you were over compensating trying to
cover up your
dark secrets but there was one other
person who was
also over compensating you
kevin even better than a plain scone
clean school
i should have known you were lying
there's nothing better than a plane
scone
this is ridiculous is it of how the pie
was disposed of
placed gently with two hands inside the
bin that's exactly how you always throw
away garbage
it is there's only one thing i still
can't figure out
why'd you do it because it's disgusting
oh my that pie is an abomination it has
beef suet and apple seeds in it
why it's a walnut pie if we brought that
to my family's house they would have
said something
i was trying to protect you why didn't
you just tell me the truth
because i love our annual trips to
saratoga springs the two of us driving
in silence
looking at the barren trees it's perfect
i i didn't want to lose that
i'm sorry i don't know why we can't
still make
the drive next year we just don't have
to buy the pie
a trip with no purpose raymond
so peralta what do you have to say for
yourself
the whole nypd knows where you are and
they're coming for you right now
okay thanks for the tip let's kill them
both get out of here before the cops
come wait no no no no i was lying about
the backup i came alone titled my sex
tape
doesn't matter you're both gonna die now
better get some corticosteroids to treat
that laryngeal fracture
sorry i couldn't bring myself to call
him a dirt bag and why would you a
dirtbag is a very useful part of the
vacuum cleaner clearly it's a compliment
oh you guys are so perfect for each
other yeah i stole those coins i can't
believe you bought that old story
they underestimated you randy just as
they underestimated raymond holt
you guys haven't been that great to me
either well you got to teach people how
you want to be treated randy dr phil
r.i.p
the point is captain holt solved the
case when no one else could he's
actually been stealing from these
archives for years you've been asleep at
the wheel alastair you're an
embarrassment really well at least i've
never confused scent augustine with
boethius oh who gives a rat's ass about
boethius wesley what are you doing kevin
i'm creating a kerfuffle oh damn
sure my husband is a hot piece of ass
but he is so much more than just that
raymond holt is as smart as anyone in
this department but he chooses to use
his intelligence to make our city a
better place
one day i hope to live up to the
standard you set you make me want to
have
a wetter brain i'm kevin
[Music]
y'all are hella specific
you